dude goes we we need to see what we're
dealing with see if the arter is cut
obviously and then all these other
nurses start surrounding him and I'm
like get back in my chair and I'm like
what's going on and he was like this is
going to hurt I need to I need to you
know with his hands he needs to open it
up spread things around and look at it
[__] and I'm like okay he's going to put
his fingers in there yeah put give me a
the Nova cane then and they're like no
time no time I'm like give me a pill
give me a they're like that no time they
were like bite down on this towel
there's a tow here I'm like and the
people start to like come around and
stuff like ins they're going to hold me
they're going to hold me down like
you're some Civil War F bro I thought
this was like what the [__] is this the
Middle
Ages the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
sickler